فمذكره داخليه لهم ماسك تحدث صدمه واسعه
باختصار ماسك يعترف بان قيمه تويتر
الحقيقيه 20 مليار دولار اي اقل من نصف
الذي دفعه في صفة الشراء قبل سته اشهر
طبعا هذه المذكره تاتي في اطار خطه اغراء
يقدمها الى الماسك لمنح اسهم للموظفين لكن
في جانبها الاخر تقدر قيمه الشركه بعشرين
مليار دولار فقط هذا التقييم الصادم ياتي
بعد الفوضى الشامله التي عاقبت استحواذ
ماسك على المنصه من تسريح موظفي ومغادره
العديد من المعلنين الكبار للمنصه على كل
حال سنتعرف اكثر على خلفيات هذه القصه معك
على
منح الاسهم للموظفين ربما هي خطوه من ماسك
للاحتفاظ بالمواهب وطمانيتهم بعد موجات
متتاليه من تسريح الاف الموظفين بخلاف
الهلع وحالات الاستقالات الجماعيه داخل
الشركه ماسكا اخبر فريق العمل ان الشركه
مرت بتغيرات جذريه لكنها ضروريه حيث كانت
على بعد اربعه اشهر فقط من الافلاس تستخدم
طريقه منح الاسهم عموما لتحفيز الموظفين
هي فرصه لشراء الاسهم التي لا يمكن بيعها
حتى وقت محدد وقد تدر ربحا جيدا اذا
ارتفعت قيمه الشركه بشكل كبير وكان ماسك
سبق واعتمد هذا النموذج نفسه مع شركته
سبيس اكس في الوثيقه الداخليه يقول ماسك
ان الطريق الى تقييم تويتر باكثر من 250
مليار دولار صعب لكنه واضح وهو ما يعني
ارتفاع قيمه الاسهم بقدر عشره اضعاف
اريد
من الكويت ينضم لنا الخبيره التقني
رونالدو اهلا بك معنا في مسائل عربيه
رمضان كريم يعني قيمه تويتر تبلغ 20 مليار
دولار اي اقل من نصف القيمه التي اشتراها
ماسكين مليار دولار دفعها قبل سته اشهر ما
سبب هذا الانخفاض الحاد في قيمه تويتر وهل
الانسحاب المعلنين هو السبب الرئيسي
المشاهدين هذا الانخفاض العملي حكى عنه
هلا هو منه انخفاض جديد لو هذا كان السبب
الرئيسي اللي كان بوقتها عم يجرب يتراجع
عن الصفقه قال هو انه هذا المبلغ 44 مليون
اكبر بكثير من قيمه الشركه بس لانه وقتها
وهو عارف انه هذا الموضوع خساره وحتى
التغريدات يعني هو اعلن عنا اجا قال انا
اشتريت لاول مره مين مليار دولار
فهو منو شيء جديد بس هلا اذا بدك هيدي
الوسيعه تسربت مثل ما هلق في كثير اشياء
عم تتسرب من داخل تويتر بسبب طرد عداد
كثير كبير من الموظفين وشفنا اليوم كمان
في تسريب للسورس كود او اذا بدك برمجيات
تويتر موجودين على الانترنت وكانوا كل
العالم صار عندهم يعني ما عم بحمل موظفين
تويتر الجميله انه صار اقل من نصف سعره
تويتر
لا لا هو اللي عم يجرب يعني هو شغله واحده
تويتر هلا حاليا عندها اشكاليه كتير كبيره
بموضوع الكشف له شفنا في دعايه على تويتر
بموضوع انه ما عم يقدر يدفعوا اجراءات
المكاتب
كبير من الموظفين شفنا انه كان تويتر من
فتره اعلن اربع مليون دولار باليوم الواحد
فكل هذا الموضوع اذا بدك تكاليف عليه
الموظفين الباقيين اجا قال انه انت بتاخده
هالاسهم على امل الاسهم بعد فتره معينه
بيرتفع اسعارهم انتم بتقدر تعملوا ارباح
كثير كبيره طيب هذا النموذج نفسه استخدمه
ماذا هو نموذج مربح ومرن في تويتر كموقع
تواصل اجتماعي
هذا النموذج هو في اذا بدك في مخاطر كتير
كبيره بس بنفس الوقت بيعتبر للموظفين يا
كنا بننجح سوا هو من فتره السابقه اعلن
انه نحن هذه المنصه ممكن من محل معين تسكر
اذا ضل الوضع هيك وشفنا الاسبوع الماضي
رحلت تويتر اغلب الموظفين مش موجودين
بعثتهم تشتغلوا من المكاتبوا فهو عم يجرب
يخلي اذا بدك الموظ ومعنيين بهالشركه مش
بس موظفين عم يقبضوا معاشات عم بيجي نحن
بننجح طيب بعد هالفتره اللي اللي مضت وبعد
استحواذ ورئاسه ماسك لتويتر هل يمكن القول
عن خاسر اكبر من هذه الصفقه نتحدث عن
المستخدمين ولا موظفين تويتر من الخاسر
الاكبر بينهم
انا برايي بعد استحواذ ماسك على تويتر
الكل عم يخسر يعني اموال كثير كبيره بهيدي
المنصه في كتير موظفين خسوا اشغالهم من
ورا طرد اغلبيه الموظفين حتى العالم بسبب
طرد الموظفين صارت تويتر اذا بدك منصه
اكثر عم تستعمل بخطاب الكراهيه عم يقدر
يعمل موديريشن على المحتوى بشكل سيء ما
حدا عم بيقدر يعمل
كل النواحي زيد عليها موضوع الاشتراكات
الشهريه كنا موضوع
كتير مهمه كمان يعني رح نحكي فيها ممكن
بحلقات ثانيه شكرا جزيلا لك من الكويت
الخبير التقني شكرا لك